hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar leveraging single cell copy
number to resolve tumor clonality i am
michelle ashton of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab root and brought to you by 10x
genomics to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.flexsim.com the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. David Wesley Craig professor
of translational genomics and
co-director Institute of translational
genomics Keck School of Medicine of USC
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. Craig you may now
begin your presentation
everyone and welcome to today's webinar
leveraging single cell copy number to
resolve tumor clonality i am michelle
ashton of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab root and brought to you by 10x
genomics to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.michigan.gov/mstep
resin tation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker dr. David Wesley Craig professor
of translational genomics and
co-director Institute of translational
genomics Keck School of Medicine of USC
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. Craig you may now
begin your presentation
okay I'm gonna go ahead
started hello my name is David Craig and
I am from the University of Southern
California within the department the
Institute of translational genomics and
I'm really excited to talk about some of
the work we've been doing looking at how
we can leverage single cell copy number
to resolve tumor clone ality and better
understand heterogeneity I kind of want
to start with this slide gives you an
overview of where I come from and I
study kind of a broad swath of different
diseases such as inherited disease such
as cancer as well as diseases of Aging
but underneath all of it is really
technology and technology is enabling
and it sees measurements that really
given us a lot of insight that's really
where where our expertise is on where we
work a lot of the informatics the data
sharing and the technology and the past
decade has seen just a revolution of
capabilities and it's all come down to
kind of one principle that matters and
it's this idea of we can better resolve
heterogeneity if we can measure things
on their atomic on their elemental on
their single singular kind of value and
that's what brings me here is the idea
we've spent a lot of time looking at
sequencing such as this and now we're
able to look at sequencing in the
context of a single cell and that I
believe is going to be enabling and so
this talk we're going to talk and look
into understanding heterogeneity and so
I think there's this inherent
understanding that cancer in itself is
usually not just one thing there's a lot
going on there's actually a lot of
different models of cancer heterogeneity
there's energy headed unity and intra
tumor heterogeneity in these models have
kind of this idea that there is a
evolution that's ongoing and this
evolution is one that's actually not one
that you want and it's one that if you
provided therapy you might select out a
sub clone that's basically able to get
around that therapy that's what these
kind of graphs show here
on the right in there's a number of
excellent reviews on this now when we
sequence this in the past we've had
abilities such as Sanger sequencing
those are kind of inherently analog
methods but even when we move to these
next-gen technologies and which reads
come from a single molecule we can't
tell which cell and so there's still
kind of bulk sequencing so what can gain
by that
what can we game in this view here is
kind of an important view because we're
going to hop back to it and it's view of
actually these dots are actually a
single cells and it's a view that has
long been have my psychologist and one
that becomes relevant in fact I'm going
to start kind of going back a period of
time in looking at one paper that we're
going to look a fair amount in it has to
do with kind of a proof of principle
working with the idea of single cell
copy number and it's a stay from 1993
looking at Saturday night
homogeneity of eight independent sites
in the case of melanoma and in this
Gorge more puts forth its series
specimens that over time have become
kind of reference standards and so this
is kind of an original paper for on the
B cell line that we're going to spend a
lot of time studying and if so line has
been saved by a lot of individuals and
so it's what it is Colo lines and we
will get into that but first let's just
take a step back and I want to take a
step back to some earlier studies where
you have these are collaborations when I
was at the translational genomics
researchers through teaching working
with on the male folks on clinical
precision medicine idea of applying on
technologies and making third Punic
decisions on it with Allen Brice Matej
forage on carp tune and group of us
sitting on the case of
cholangiocarcinoma and in this this is
one whereby you're looking at copy
number traces at this time and this is
basically the idea that we're trying to
see where there were applications kind
of indicated red and where there were
deletion
of this cat's we speak of a a spike
you're on chromosome eight and that
spike is actually there's a gene
underneath it in the Gina is in RG 1 so
you might interpret this to say okay
part of chromosome 8 is amplified the
other part might be deleted it's
important to note this y-axis really
doesn't tell us copy number it's
actually giving us a full change as
compared to a normal and so that'll be
important later now what really kind of
matters from this is that a treatment
decision was really made on this case
and the the principle was to go after
the in our G 1 and so following that
there was a series of cytology images
taken and the idea was to kind of look
at this not just from this kind of bulk
sequencing but try your best to look at
from a single cell sequencing modality
the treatment occurred and then they we
redid the entire analysis and when we
did that we saw that sure not that
treatment that was targeting this in our
g1 locus was gone but there was a new
peak what we've done with some selected
a clone and this time the idea was to
target this clone with erlotinib
and so you can see here this Peaks kind
of gone away we clearly have selected a
very different clone it looks different
and we're able then to kind of verify
this by looking at the Scientology these
again are single cells one of the things
are noticing here and this is going back
in time and saying okay when we saw this
boat setting we really wanted to get a
single-cell view to take a picture of
what was going on this is actually part
of this study now after that occurred
there was actually another relapse and
so this is a time series in which now
we're on the third round and we've
treated two different targets and when
it comes back well we bring back this
locus here
and what also happens is there are some
new mutations and so what you're seeing
here is kind of back and forth with the
oncologist looking at the copying of
data and basically giving therapeutic
options and they're effectively doing
their job
but there are sub clones and if we can
get a better idea of these sub clones we
might understand a little bit better how
we can treat cancer especially very
difficult or current cases so once again
we're going to zoom into the single cell
traces so what you see here is this kind
of premise where these changes matter
this is again evident have a game we see
probably a focal amplifier I I think
it's just best to take away that they're
they're single several single cell
validation using fluorescence so that's
a motivating factor studying and
understanding cancer and its
heterogeneity let's get back to this
case that we're going to put a lot of
thought into to see investigate kind of
the utility of single cell sequencing
for copy number DNA and so this is a
cell line that is available through a
TCC Cola 89 and the premise was if we
wanted to the premise actually for us
with this cell line started back with if
we want to take those days of precision
medicine forward we need to come up with
a reference standard something that we
could take within clinical labs and
validate and so there was a series of
groups and collaborations with the folks
in British Columbia one group Illumina
and a couple other groups as well and
what we did was create kind of a guy gia
was a reference standard for cancer
sequencing for those of you who might
think of like the thousand on the the
genome in a bottle there is this na12878
this individual from Utah so it's kind
of a reference standard for germ line
sequencing that's important for
inherited disease but actually cancer
when we're looking at tumor specific
alterations didn't really have a great
reference standard so this was kind of
an agreement between
all of us to kind of work together and
take a series of samples basically grow
up cells independently sequencing
independently analyze them in a number
of ways and come up with kind of a set
of ones that were reproducible
repeatable we actually brought in a lot
of the original data this line have been
studied before we started this this was
published a couple years ago it was a
Aaron pleasance and colleagues with Mike
sense group actually went and so we went
and downloaded their data and what we
have here are kind of three grows from a
stock and then sequencing kind of
creating a cross analysis to identify
some true set to publish it in what we
were able to do was really characterize
single nucleotide variants and some of
the insertions deletions we have here
the kind of authors this was actually
communicated when you're laying in turn
answer but there's also several other
individuals in here we would have these
meetings and discussion on the copy
number and we're always some things
going on that we fully didn't appreciate
and there were differences too and
differences would be expected and so we
kind of characterize these differences
but the decision was well something
different with a copy number I'm going
to show you a little bit that let's just
focus on what we understand well and
that were these mutations so these are
some figures that show the differences
between these different passages you're
going to this little chromosome 1p loss
here that we put there with something
that we could noted and it carried with
a fair number of changes we kind of
expect some differences but this was one
we actually had a fair amount of
discussion on at the time and this is a
trace of actually some of the analysis
that some of the Illumina folks there
knows or some of the teaching folks we
would look at this is the trace of log
fold change versus the the normal in
this case it's a B cell line and what
you see here is in all of these traces
they look fairly the same but actually
there are some differences and the
Illumina folks would bring up this fact
that there's something going on here at
chromosome 1 and
and there was a lot of discussion of
what this is and what this means
it was the teachin getting a sample was
it losing it kind of looks like it loses
an arm here that was one of the
descriptions when I go back and work at
the email is that this part was lost now
that was where we were able to leave it
we wanted to get the better house to
share it and kind of allow the community
to you don't do their own analysis
identify some things now one of the
important things occurred a little bit
much about that time is actually there
were spectral karyotyping kind of the
original single-cell method done on this
this cell line and I want to kind of
point this because we started we looked
at this actually after the publication
what we could see is there is a
tremendous amount of an employee the you
know you see multiple copies of
chromosome three four six eight nine
that brings forth one of the inherent
shortcomings if we you know walk back to
this life I kept saying that this here
you know we actually the y-axis is a
little tricky we can say relative will
change we actually don't know if it's a
copy number gained or not because we
have to assume how many overall copies
there are because mathematically we just
can't derive it there various tricks
were used in you know the bridge to the
BC group very good said we tried 40
different tools and none of a match
exactly what the true answer was ahead
of time and it's actually interesting I
have a bunch of notes here from Paul
Edwards and the individual who put this
together and these are the notes that
they had and they did this great thing
put this forth as is and they kind of
described a few things in here and I'm
going to highlight a few there's
evidence for on a somewhat karyotype
evolution in Duluth Indo reduplicating
there's a lot of information there's 311
s you can see that this last sentence
here is going to become important a
likely explanation is that the consensus
should include a 118 translocation
that's really interesting so that
actually wasn't discussed and thought
about we were
look at the boat sequencing because it
wasn't where we were going it's one of
those things which we saw the 1p but we
didn't really see anything going on with
18 wasn't necessarily the focus but once
we see this it sort of makes sense so
there have been a lot of papers on this
line I'm going to show you a few just
highlight that they exist and so there
are these efforts to develop these copy
number tools that allow us to see the
copy number changes underlying a trimmer
and the heterogeneity one example here
is a crest paper which is a algorithm by
the washing of Oaks get in this
algorithm you can see that they're kind
of going through and developing it they
actually do look at cola eight to nine
as kind of their standard and one of the
things that's interesting to look at is
you don't really see you see kind of
acknowledgment that there is something
else going on but not an ability to
really kind of frame every part of it
there's some other analyses papers it's
actually focused on clonal heterogeneity
this is in a pond formatic stirred a
little bit later and then this it says
in the tumor sample we observe that
there's events of two threes and there's
aneuploidy assuming that the simplest
here the speculation is confirmed the by
previous data characterized genome-wide
copy number five six when you read this
you kind of get the sense that it's
unclear whether or not those
heterogeneity or not
something is going on and so I think
that most folks who would look at this
in the community you know would say that
yeah there's something going on but
we're just not understanding it and so
this takes us to our method and that's a
lot of background but you need to
understand kind of the insight that kind
of comes with looking at single-cell
data and so I have these three plots
here and we've kind of talked a little
bit about spectral karyotyping hyman by
no means an expert in this in fact this
study has taught me to appreciate how
we're not back to the future moment of
appreciating how right this was when we
moved to single cell because essentially
this becomes something that's available
for next-gen informatics
this is something that you know we can
go a lot further than and we do that
with the technology and what we were
using here was kind of one of the very
first iterations of the single-cell
sequencing of DNA - from technics
genomics the idea in principle here is
to get a low pass sequencing per genome
on the data set that we have is really
focusing on sequencing about 1,400 cells
generates a lot of reads but if you were
actually trying to figure out the mean
coverage pervaiz for cell it's actually
pretty low now we'll talk about that and
what that means but one thing it'd be
could mean if you make a copy number
call over several mega bases well you
may be able to add them all up and to
identify it and that's exactly what this
second thing this kind of analysis
focuses on so I don't go through these
sample prep methods there's their focus
to me to kind of explain it but the key
thing is is we can get from a cell and
we can actually get to sequence level
data where the barcode indicates which
cell it came from and we can put
together alive in the genome and
identify variants that occurs through an
idea of kind of partitioning I'm going
to show you a little bit more on this in
the coming slide and making single cell
copy number columns and what we want to
do is I want to take you to one of these
single cells and so if this was a plot
like we were used to but other single
cell you can kind of see one big changes
to do it the result for you by knowing
it's a single cell it's much easier to
get an absolute number on ploidy the
y-axis becomes meaningful it's actually
pretty huge because you can say how many
copies of the chromosomes are there okay
so we can look at if there if this is
showing you four profiles perhaps we can
put them all together cluster them and
identify subclones and that's exactly
what this kind of first graph is showing
you where we've taken all of these
traces and we've kind of shown them
where this is chromosome 1 2 3 4 and the
ploidy is plotted as a heat
and each one of these traces is just one
line now so we're now seeing a picture
that we haven't seen before but we can
clearly see that they're clusters now
one aspect we can see that the cluster
is this is showing you post actually
tell mr. discovery and that was using an
algorithm developed by is this really
developed implemented by the tannic
Stokes discriminant analysis of
principal components and in in this
particular plot we're looking at two
kind of components and what you can see
is existence of kind of four main
clusters we could do further analysis
and shows that there's an optimal number
but we could see that some of the cells
are following here is a group falling
here we're pulling here in a group
following here that's pretty neat so
what that's saying is that our groups
are different based on chromosome one
and actually a little bit more complex
and perhaps even we were thinking about
so let's go ahead and dig a little bit
more into that so now we have four major
clones and when I saw this plot is like
aha and that's actually where I kind of
start working with this data was we'd
sequence if we had sequenced it we
looked at this nerve like what do you
make of this I'm like I knew there was
heterogeneity and wow I can see things I
never saw before
so that brings us through this analysis
of what we wanted to do and we worked
with textbooks on with clustering these
taking a BAM clusters and creating at
that time little mini dance and the idea
we had there was let's create a BAM of
cluster a B C and D and look at variants
first type of iya that we look at we're
single nucleotide variant we'll discuss
as we go but also copy number variants
looking anomaly three pairs repair that
map to different places structural
breakpoints the idea that and some of
these bands would contain a bunch of
cells someone contained a few ourselves
because it happened to be for the
smaller group so we had four bands and
those four bands were the four major
groups and we basically treated this
like we would anything else and
basically do analysis of one versus
another one versus
the control various scenarios
so this been allowed us to look at
something important clones we've now
discovered some clones can we gain any
insight that we didn't have before and
so here is seeing a picture of some of
these clones and I like this picture a
lot this is actually a picture and
chromosome 18 because you can see so
many features so this is one of our
clones and what you can see here is this
is probably over a 10 KB region we could
see a stacking of reeds and the second
of reeds actually suggest a deletion
we've got colouring such that we can see
anomalous reads reads to go from here to
here the read reads joining each other
see these guys right here this is a
polymorphic slip and inheritance right
there you can see how it would be
heterozygous but you can kind of see
here and if you map the whole bunch of
these you would see that there's a loss
of at Oregon City it basically looks
like this clone only has really one of
the two parental points this one here
it's harder to see but if we looked at
another we could stack them together
look at a loss of heterozygosity
analysis this is this and that so one of
the things that's really nice is you get
a sense of the accuracy of the
clustering by the way because if the
clustering did not use a lot of this
information what you can see is in this
10 KB region and the clustering with
space of much bigger window don't see
random reads floating in there that's
one reason why that's quite excited by
it because it looked like the clustering
was kind of interesting but let's look
at actually this key region this jump
chromosome one and what one of the
things we did was we tried to zoom in
here and what we were able to serve was
a translocation to chromosome 1010 P
11.2 and so now this is a new picture
we've zoomed out this is actually then a
kind of a break on these different Hama
different clusters and so you can see
some of them you see the drop and some
of them you don't
that's really except we can zoom in
further we can get base level resolution
and when we zoom in far enough if you
use these traces you probably wonder
about those these are what's usually
thrown out this is a strictly bwa
alignment these are basically than the
reeds where every single base doesn't
match that's the point the exact point
where the translocation occurs and so
we're able to get single cell based
level resolution of these now each one
of these reeds may come from a different
cell remember we're looking at a
collection of cells but we still have
that ability so what you can see here
then is the ability to then map travel
tations down to a single molecule level
and what we're depending there on is by
having enough really kind of cells in
the group to identify them we are able
to go a little bit further and find
another translocation that jumped to
from 10 P 14 to 18 P 11 0.32 this is
where the real insight came in that we
never had before
what this suggested that we had was a
hybrid chromosome from chromosome 1 from
10 jumping comas my teeth still here
here here this actually flips around
it's actually a kind of derivative of
chromosome 18 and this is something that
Paul Edwards kind of talked about when
we kind of went to him and talked to him
about his results so we have this
picture of seeing all of it now let's go
back to our original data I said we saw
this stuff before and so we went back to
the bolt data from back in the day
since 2012 actually even though the
paper was published later what we can
see is that the events that we're seeing
here were found in the previous
sequencing and that the TJ line didn't
show the hybrids so what it suggests is
that this hybrid was somehow lost and
that kind of makes sense because this
would be largely unstable and usually
lost and this actually brings us to this
overall model let's picture the
chromosome plots where we can then
understand and build things up and I'm
going to fold in one last piece of data
its footage down and you can fold it a
lot remember I talked that you got loss
of heterozygosity this plot here we
start looking at a month we have single
cells this is actually the trace this is
developed on by Jessica Aldrich which
was a tool kind of looking a copy number
where you can see these events but we've
actually mapped what we're calling
allele frequency or lots of errors I
guess and what you don't see them tons
and tons that actually jump to 0 1 so we
put these numbers here we also see
something on chromosome 8 and so we can
identify differences between Group A and
Group C we can identify differences for
the snips which have lots of
heterozygosity we can find structural
breakpoint differences and we can find
copy number differences we look at the
bold sequence e we can do something
similar so just to make sure I've
covered every project figure this is how
many reads are jumping between the two
chromosomes that we actually see the
mapping for there was a part where we've
seen additional that occurring on
chromosome 8 and this events also lost
and there's actually a really elegant
explanation for a lot of this but one
thing I want you to know some of the
parallels are that effectively at the
same points and they are actually the
exact endpoint the cycle rendering we
see that the T jump bolt actually is
very similar to one of our subgroups
this group C and so it's fascinating to
see a recapitulated time and again but
it showed kind of a general model that
was overly occurring again and again in
this model where we have kind of a
starting cell and we're growing and
starts out with this one P 10 to 18 to
this aberrant chromosome aging that's
often lost and so on several of the
sites which had the bulk sequencing had
all of them but some of the other ones
didn't and so that gave us an infant we
didn't have before in what I like about
this is it shows the richness in a very
boring topic it's cell line grow
so now I'm going to jump into some
things that reason why we were doing
this from first lace which was to move
to patient sample so the idea that we
use is : online we really bit insights
and explained things we weren't
previously able to we took in this case
and this is actually a little bit while
ago he said of renal cell carcinoma
disassociated home cells and had them
sequenced as well and with this single
cell method you can see the number of
cells are being sequenced eat here
it's are a bit lower because you know
when we thought about we really only
wanted we didn't need that many one
thing you can do just like the next-gen
sequencing it's kind of tune this
towards a goal but the sequence in the
neighborhood of 750 I'm going to show
you each one of these and you know what
they'll be this part where for I think
some individuals will mail it 800 I see
what's going on in there and one thing
is if we're looking at a regular
specimen that came from a patient we
might be a mixture of the stromal cells
and the tumor cells a tumor normal
mixture and that's actually what you're
seeing here and so if you look at this
is basically trace it and we could say
this is about half is diploid and half
is tumor and we do see actually some
evidence for kind of clusters right we
see these kind of blocks this one we
actually see only a little bit of tumor
about 15 percent of the cells here we
see about 20 percent of the cells what's
really great about this is there's a lot
of stage which talk about tomorrow a
sequencing in here we're able to we
could just focus in on these trimmer
examples we could identify those
mutations that were specific to the
tumor exactly what we did by the way
when I dig in there and show you that
first thing though that was obvious to
us was that we were able to see distinct
chromosome 3 profiles among all of the
different cell groups and what we could
see is on these different cells we could
see this is quite a core of them for us
which was on chromosome 3 which contains
it's kind of key
driver mutation and VHL one now one
question you might have is could you
detective Gary could you detect the in a
small portion of yourself so what we did
was in this case we ran a stroke that we
created a little mini ban on this slice
of 51 cells versus all of these 800 and
then looked at the calls and so what did
we identify one of the variants called
actually was a severely low number of
reads was one of the canonical driver
mutations for this and so it's kind of
neat to be able to see this actually
being called now there's a stochastic
nature on that in fact that we're
looking at something that's probably 10%
of cells but we're able to pick it up
and actually it's a heterozygote so this
is actually we were able to show that as
well this is another case where we're
actually making an IND L being called
from the non-deployed and took what
these are inverted and you can see that
there and so now in this case it's a
little bit more straightforward so that
actually shows you something that you
kind of was hoping to see we didn't see
it with Co way to 9 because it turn a
cell line growth you probably don't
acquire a ton of mutations and we kind
of didn't expect to it's really though
the term revolution that's occurring
with their nest tissue that we wanted to
see in fact we can see so that kind of
brings us to the end of this talk and
really darson conclusions this could be
called facts in future at some point but
single-cell sequencing of DNA
significantly improves our ability to
understand to revolution and tumor
heterogeneity particularly those tumors
that are driven by aneuploidy and that
identification of the siene clones are
groups really opens up subclonal
analysis so structural variants snips or
LOH mutation the snip LOH can identify
track chromosome lossing games I feel
there's a lot that can be done an
analysis size which I'll never be able
to pursue I'm hopeful that somebody will
we were able to use breakpoint analyses
to show things that we weren't able to
show before and distinctly linked to
regions something we could not
necessarily you know we didn't do before
and get a clearer picture of tumor claw
evolution and the one thing it does is
it helps you understand what is really
going on here so strings my last slide
and I want to thank you guys all for
listening with me this is a lot of the
work is led by Enrique who work closely
with the 10x team and really was a key
person that was interfacing with us and
implementing and developing a lot
particularly question was on the
Chaminade pictured here but with the
team of folks including clay on
experimental side new jamming the
computational same type blood sort of
people that are here some of the key
insights also big came from Paul Edwards
who really which is wonderful too just
to put out so much of his data online
since we found it and gained insight I
think that was really an incredible part
to that it was really through Mary's
work the single cell on patient data we
saw is Lee and John and then we also
brought in just gonna tweak the the LOH
algorithms a little bit to get those to
work and bring that in as an addendum
and so we have all of this the papers in
review but of course we do put things
out pre-publication
that will be available as well so thank
you for your time thank you dr. Craig
for your presentation we will now start
a live Q&A portion of the webinar a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop-down box located on the
far left of the presentation window
labeled ask a question and click the
send button dr. Craig will answer as
many questions as time permits all right
let's get started our first question is
moving beyond cell lines what other
applications are there for an assay like
this
so thank you that question and that's
really an important question because
it's at the Craig stuff I'm enthusiastic
about the ability to look at single
cells and really the applications are an
understanding tumor evolution and tumor
clonality within specimens most of the
time when we're looking at a specimen
that's been taken from a patient it's
oftentimes not just pure tumor there's
often normal stromal cells as we saw and
there's also going to be a tumor
evolution that's occurring them we will
see some cells from all of those so what
we're excited and what we've been
working on the most is really
implementing this in the context of
different tumor specimens and that's
really where the excitement is that that
we're currently on so we're looking at
endometrial we're looking at ovarian
prostate breast cancer and to try to
understand within of course the tumor
particularly those that have been
treated multiple times do we see
multiple clones and can we resolve them
using on this copy number driven
approach to resolving the heterogeneity
great thank you okay your next question
is a two-part question what are the
limitations of bulk seek for this and
can the same work be done with
tumor-normal samples and informatics
methods so that's a question that gets
to the heart of you know the idea that
if we push a bunch of things together
what can we resolve in terms of a
mixture and one one part of that is
whenever you you see this presentation
or any others it's always like okay well
we can see that in the bulk but could we
have discovered it and that often is not
the case and in this particular example
this tumor had been sequence multiple
times by multiple groups had very deep
and we clearly see evidence for all
three of its but we were never able to
really resolve all the features that
were going on and so there are certain
things where you just lose information
and so in large part understanding
clonality informatica lis is not
something done routinely so in other
words tipper medics really hasn't gotten
to that point being able to do it
perfectly there is some really work we
have published on this this work was led
by Rebecca Halperin who is faculty
member out of Tegan where that she looks
at how well we can do in that we found
that we had to go in sequence very deep
around oh gosh 800 X and and we would
have to mall the copy number in the
snips but and so depending on the nature
other we were able to see some but not
all that that in itself means that we're
kind of spending money elsewhere
so there's a certain big advantage to
this so a certain point we can
definitely do this and resolve some
aspects informatica lee but it's nothing
that compares towards the rid the
ability once you already have these
separate
so if you do want to see kind of the
extent of that you can look up on
Halperin's paper on this that we wrote
together on it but and you can also go
through the positive predictive value
all the places where things don't work
out well where they do but there's a
reason why having developed those
methods that we are enthusiastic about
being able to directly do the sickle
cell sequencing as the DNA and it really
does aid and actually show insights that
we never saw before as evidenced by this
particular study of kind of our
benchmark right so there's just certain
things we can I guess great thank you
okay your next question how many cells
can I load into a chip channel and what
recovery rate should I expect so there's
a certain part I'm going to defer to
some other that has to be on the phone
culpa the broader question gets into how
many cells do we go after and we've
taken different approaches to this
question on and in some cases what we've
done is we've set some set things up so
that we could do more cells are fewer
cells and a lot of it depends on the
nature of the tumor that we're studying
what our goals are in other words what
sort of subclones to pick up and for
many of our studies we've been
sufficient we've kind of designed for
five hundred to a thousand for some
particular ones we do want to go a
little bit more it's very much dependent
on the context of the assay now I take
this part and because there's a
technical aspect to it I will defer to
colleagues we've also have to be on the
phone from 10x and so maybe they can
pick up from there on the technical
detail
so for our CMB assay we recommend
loading from 1600 as a minimum up to
31,000 cells as input and you can expect
up to a 15% recovery rate after
sequencing of those inputted cells we do
have a technical note new on the support
site for this DN BFA section and it will
help you to select number of cells if
you have other data as far as if you
know what size events you're looking for
and also sequencing considerations and
then to add to that when I said to
5-iron fields usually that's what I end
up looking for the target so actually we
would be loading in more we it's one of
those when you get the PI answering the
question all you often care about are
the results you know how many end up on
there and so I think that's exactly why
I wanted the 10x folks to jump in on
that one to help out with those details
thank you all right next question if I
decide to reduce sequencing is that okay
and what will be the trade-off
so you know I think with a lot of
next-generation sequencing one of the
key aspects is that fundamentally it was
a shift going to sequencing kind of
these quantum are these singular events
and that allowed us for the first time
to be able to really control error
towards our goals and what I mean by
that is if we think about some of the
original you know the projects like
thousand genomes it was 4x sequencing
which seems kind of crazy but to
identify all of the polymorphisms within
a population greater than one percent
really that was all that was needed so
the original project there was for now
when we talk about sequencing individual
genomes there was there's a
recommendation that's 100 except we'll
get you fairly good accuracy now in a
clinical lab often we do exome
sequencing that gets to 80 X 90 X 100x
for example and that really gets you to
another level of quality and so decent
parallels I think have the potential to
exist with single-cell sequencing when I
think about this and I think about our
specific utility we're often going to be
looking at kind of solid tumors and
looking at heterogeneity and trying to
identify clones sub clones that are in
the neighborhood of about 5 to 10
percent so we can kind of model that and
how many cells we think we would need to
be able to get and in the end that
determines a lot of our kind of costs
and so forth I think it's so so that
kind of frames it in terms of how many
cells we want to look at and the example
would be if we would really want to cut
identify for example a mutation specific
to a clone at 10 percent you know I'd
like to really see you know a good
number of reads there and so I might be
wanting to see 150 cells are 200 cells
or something like that to be able to
identify that which then would
well probably going to need upwards of
12 watching 50 rim cells right so it
kind of really depends on the goals
that's in the case of trying to identify
a single nucleotide variant so there's
some variability and the way our
experiments are design we often retain
the ability to go back and either
experimentally to the sequencing or
going back to the acid go deeper into
that specimen in a second round so
oftentimes we do kind of true to the
ability to take certain samples and look
at them at a deeper coverage by adding
additional experimental data later so
that's kind of how we attack it by
basically having a baseline and then if
we need to for a specific study go
deeper through additional experiments
and that's one of the effective ways we
use to manage kind of the overall costs
I don't know if 10x has any thoughts on
this in terms of their recommendations
that's kind of a specific kind of
example in our case anybody from the
tenex have more broader answers towards
optimal study design we would recommend
customers refer to the techmount that I
refer to prior just depending on what
information they have and how they can
frame their experiment that document is
really useful which touches upon
sequencing number of cells to be
inputted as well as what event size
you're looking for if that's on a single
cell level or if you're okay with
looking across a cluster of cells
I think one of the things that's you
know kind of everybody has something
different they say so for us you'll see
Philly's so my thoughts you'll see a lot
of bias towards soon kind of collection
themselves in many of our stays if we
will my see in event a single cell I
don't think that we can experimentally
interpret it or at least we're not
planning to it's really when we see kind
of a the you know the suggestion of a
subclone that's you know somewhere in
the range of one to five percent that
we'd want to look at now one can see and
speculate in five scenarios where a
single cell is informative it's just not
part of our particular experimental
design
great thank you all right your next
question what is the largest cell size I
can use for this assay I have no idea
and I would really like to hear the
textbooks answer that I have not thought
of that question
so we've tested up to 30 micron diameter
size cells with our sandy solution if
you're testing something larger than
that we generally recommend isolating
nuclei and we do have a protocol on the
support site that addresses frozen
tissue as well as fresh or cryopreserved
cell lines to give you an idea or an
outline of how you can go about prepping
cells or nuclei from your tissue or your
cell line if you do use cells that are
larger than 30 microns you risk clogging
the channel of the chip and therefore
you'll get a clog and you won't be able
to recover your emulsion and proceed
with the assay
you
thank you okay can I a grenade multiple
libraries that were sequenced from
different parts of the tumor to create
one set so this is a really interesting
question and I think one of the core
aspects is the heterogeneity
particularly in solid tumors and there's
a lot to that and I big different fields
of different expertise you know there
may be talking about you know kind of at
the edge of a tumor on at the boundaries
that maybe there are different cells and
there are all these interesting
questions that have to go in terms of
overall tumor metastasis and so for a
large part of many states you can
imagine scenarios and there's a great
work by Christina Curtis that kind of is
published in Nature Genetics talks about
this big bang theory of of cancer
genomics but you can also see it seated
and so many others works where you're
going to see underlying heterogeneity
and it may be different in different
parts and so it would be really great to
look at different parts of the tumor and
what you would be curious about earth
would some of the dominant clones be
present in you know let's say the
boundary the leading edge versus the the
kind of a let's say bulk of the tumor
that's kind of interesting
there are so many different aspects that
we think about with this and as far as
how do we bring them together and
aggregate them well I think that we
haven't explored all the different ways
we can do that but I can definitely say
that being able to look them all
together I would suppose that I might
try to actually aggregate them all and
do the clustering together and I would
try to not have it together it's a great
question it would be part of a strategy
analysis wise I don't know if anybody on
the tonight site or did the clustering
would have any opinions if they took to
different parts of the tumor I actually
might try to have them aggregated we'd
try to do both anybody over there have
any thoughts on a few wood secrets like
the leading edge of a tumor in the
middle of the tumor whether or not you
would run it as a single analysis or
kind of keep them separate and then
compare
yes hi this is Andrew with 10x I'm in
the biome from a tech support group yeah
we actually earlier this year released a
new pipeline within cell range or DNA
called Agri pipeline and this allows the
user to aggregate multiple libraries
together into a single output a set of
output files up to 20,000 cells and we
actually have a new tutorial available
online now that illustrates how to do
this using a breast cancer data set
where we have multiple sections from the
same tumor that have been aggregated so
you can find out on the 10x genomics
support site clicking on the single cell
CMD solution software and tutorials so
Andrew I know a little time can you tell
us then whether or not you think that
you would be able to resolve things that
you wouldn't normally by putting them
all together
well at least in the breast cancer data
set that we looked at we can certainly
see that there's like an additional
level of heterogeneity that wouldn't be
obvious from just analyzing any single
library so yeah there is variation like
spatially across the different sections
of the tumor
okay
right thank you okay it looks like we
have time for one more question and this
question is is it possible to get SNP
information from this data for mutation
detection so that questions has a little
bit of complexity to it so a snipping
snip single nucleotide polymorphism is
typically something that's polymorphic
and inherited throughout a population
and so that would be a germline event so
in our presentation we do go and we look
at where these go from being
heterozygous to homozygous like from you
know the deletion but I suppose the
question is probably more actually
looking at single nucleotide variation
or insertions and deletions are specific
to a clone and mutation driving a clone
for example and so that's something that
within the coal 89 we did not observe
and you might think ok that's reasonable
and considering you know for the most
part you're you were looking at
comparing different clones and you're
only looking at 10 passages but actually
very much so we can you know in various
days we have been able to identify
mutation specific to a clone I know that
we've been using kind of our own
in-house approaches to these but largely
that has aggregated together bands and
then being able to you do mutation
specific calling comparing them I know
that we had conversations at the
tynix folks about them kind of creating
additional solutions to doing mutation
specific calling but let me tell you
that's one of the reasons why this is so
cool I mean if it were just CMB then
that would be good but what's really
great is to be able to use that and the
subclones
to identify those mutations and so yes
I'm very enthusiastic yes to that
the number of cells of course and then
I'm curious on the tonight side if they
have duty as suggested any like
supported solutions
hi-yah this is Andrew again so we heard
during the webinar from dr. Craig about
how his team analyzed snv's for
subclones so I just wanted to point out
that in the latest version of cell
Ranger DNA we offer a BAM slice pipeline
which was not available at the time when
the when the paper was done but it
basically allows us to subset the BAM
file which contains all reads in the
data set by the cell bar code or the 10x
bar code and this way the user can do
their own snv calling on the subclones
using third-party tools and we do have
actually dr. Craig presented this
earlier in the webinar on the Colo 829
data set splitting up the BAM file by
the four groups
a B C and D that were identified with
discriminant analysis of principal
components so in that tutorial I just
mentioned and the last question we also
have an example of how to use the band
slice pipeline to two subsets that BAM
file by the four groups that that dr.
Craig mentioned specifically and we also
noticed that yeah another preprint came
out yesterday from dr. ben Rafael's
group using a novel method called chisel
that uses low coverage single-cell
genome information to call snv's and
determine clone a letís so that's also
really exciting something I've been
looking to in detail yet but as it just
came out yesterday but so this field is
evolving quickly yeah so the one thing I
would add to what Andrew just mention I
haven't looked at Ben's on preprint but
for the smv calling I think we didn't
mention it but we've looked at a few
different tools pragmatically we we have
had the best success just using stroker
which is a tool that's implemented by
members of the Illumina informatics team
and we found that that works very well
without any need for additional
filtering we also looked at meu tech
that worked as well require a little bit
more filtering
kinda was enthusiastic about the stroke
just because it does some kind of micro
alignment micro assembly within it so I
think that there will be multiple
approaches to the mutation calling I
could just say that you know
pragmatically we have been having
success just on breaking out the stroke
of tool and applying it straight up to
the slice bands so that's kind of been
how we've been attacking it seems to be
working very well thank you I would like
to once again thank dr. Craig and the
10x genomics team for their time today
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
I don't I think as we enter this kind of
a new era of moving from single book
both collections of cells to single
cells we're seeing kind of the same sort
of kind of revolutionary ability to see
things that we couldn't see before that
we saw when we moved into next-gen you
know so next-gen sequencing was about
sequencing and molecules and and looking
at the Melander lying molecular events
from a singular point of view and now we
can do this a cellular level and now
really it's the DNA that's allowing and
starting to drive these as well and so
it's it's taking a step beyond
single-cell RNA sequencing and there's -
there's such quite a bit that can be
understood from sequencing of the DNA of
single cells even when it often
technically has challenges we're able to
resolve very important disease relevant
problems that have been core to our
field particular cancer genetics for so
long so it's exciting kind of early days
of that and I think that there's a lot
of great stuff to come
you
from the 10x 145 I would just say if
you're planning experiments and you
think the CMV solution is something that
maybe can help you answer your questions
please email us at support it - next
genomics comm and we'd be more than
happy to help you work through that
experimental design or help you answer
specific questions about the workflow or
the bioinformatics end thank you
thanks so much I'd also like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their questions any questions we did
not have time for today we'll be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor 10x genomics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand and
laberd's for you when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's event until next time
goodbye